Wow this is a Callaway Corvette Aero
Eggen it is the most powerful car made
in the US period it's supercharged with
the supercharger pushing up all the way
through the hood 767 horsepower this car
will go from 0 to 60 in 2.7 seconds
which is nuts so let's put it to the
test I'm going to head out to Rockaway
for lunch and we'll see what this
[Music]
so Callaway the very same name that
engineers golf clubs modified raised
Corvettes and in this arrow wagon the
main upgraded to the supercharged engine
and it's so fast the fuel efficiency is
27 miles per gallon at feed on the
highway that's like prime optimum
conditions but it's still pretty
incredible considering most cars with
757 horsepower get like 12 to 13 miles
per gallon so the Aero wagon part of the
Callaway Corvette is totally new this
year it's a huge departure from what
typical Corvette looks like and that's
by design the trunk is enormous and
that's what you're really getting by
choosing to have this option the
interior is just like the regular
Corvette that you buy directly from GM
it's very much like a cockpit
so the Belt Parkway isn't exactly the
Autobahn but I was able to get a feel
for the strength of the supercharger and
I made it down to Rockaway Beach in no
time flat and the starting price is
about 130 thousand dollars the money
goes towards the engineering that makes
this car so powerful and fast but still
that is so much cheaper than what you
might find at Ferrari or McLaren or
Lamborghini this can keep up with all of
those cars and it's a far less expensive
[Music]
[Music]